Modern. Fucking. Companies.
Everyone looks so fucking young!
How is anybody looking
in supposed to
a sense of the
the fucking hierarchy?
Jesus Christ!
Half you c***s coming out
of that building are dressed
like fucking gap year students,
I mean what
Fuck!
Children, the whole Smithereen building
is a box full of fucking children.
Getting their fingers everywhere
beep beep beep beep beep
beep beep beep beep
Wiping their shit,
your fucking app shit up
everybody's phone.
Everywhere you look people
are hooked on the things.
It's like chain smoking!
Did you make a lot of cash
out of that did you?
And you lot are hooked
on them as well.
Every single person that
comes out of that building
is like... bloop bloop bloop
People don’t even look up anymore
the sky could turn fucking purple
and you c***s wouldn’t
even notice for a month.
You didn’t even look up and
look where that got you
sitting in the back like that.
An intern,
why didn’t you dress
like a fucking intern?
Jesssssuuus